There's an old expression: curiosity killed
the cat.
It's a quick way of saying that if you ask
too many questions, you may not like the answers
— or troubles — you get as a result.
This particular adage would certainly serve
viewers of the John Wick series well: ask
too many questions, and your head might start
to hurt.
Here are some (but not all) of the biggest
unanswered questions that we came up with
by the end of John Wick: Chapter 3: Parabellum.
And if you haven't seen the movie yet, plug
some bullets into your ears — major spoilers
ahead.
Each installment of the John Wick saga seems
to introduce more important characters from
John's past, featuring some pretty big time
Hollywood actors playing the parts.
While these new faces fill in some blanks,
they certainly raise plenty of questions of
their own.
Sofia, played by Halle Berry, probably has
some of the most memorable and exciting scenes
with Wick.
The two team up (along with her very good
dogs) to get John on the road to meeting the
Elder of the High Table, and kill a bunch
of jerks together in the process.
When all is said and done, Sofia's debt to
John is paid — and she seems to think that
he actually owes her another favor now.
But while just about everyone else who comes
into contact with Wick throughout his period
of being excommunicado gets punished by the
Adjudicator or Zero and his ninja goons, we
never see the consequences of Sofia's decision
to help John.
Will the High Table exact vengeance on Sofia
in the next film?
Will she be forced out of her own hotel management
position as well?
Will her mysterious hidden daughter come into
play as a result?
The biggest source of conflict within John
Wick: Chapter 3 was the friction between the
characters and the rules dictating their secret
society.
It all starts in John Wick: Chapter 2, when
John breaks the rules inside the Continental
by killing Santino D'Antonio, the crime lord
who'd tricked John into killing his sister
Gianna D'Antonio — all so Santino could
ascend to her seat on the High Table.
Everyone who helps John afterward is likewise
punished for breaking yet more rules.
Meanwhile, John travels across the world to
meet with the Elder, who apparently runs the
High Table, and who tasks him with killing
Winston, the Continental Manager, to make
things right.
But let's be real: how do you get to run the
High Table?
And just how do all these crazy rules get
decided?
For a group of lawless murderers, they sure
do seem to be sticklers for regulations.
Moreover, how does someone get a job with
the High Table?
The Adjudicator sure seemed pretty young to
have such a powerful position.
Were representatives from the High Table showing
up at colleges, offering exciting jobs in
rule enforcement among secret assassin societies?
And how come John never managed to climb the
corporate ladder and get his own seat considering
how he's literally the greatest assassin who
ever lived?
You'd think they'd give him a seat just to
give the other million or so assassins a chance
to make a buck.
The end of John Wick Chapter 2 features a
pretty cool moment.
In a park in New York City, Winston declares
John excommunicado and the price on his head
goes worldwide.
After that, tons of phones start ringing all
around John and his dog, seeming to indicate
that in addition to all of the assassins John
faced already in the movie, all these people
are likewise hired guns.
John Wick Chapter 3 continues with this thread,
as would-be badasses all over the world spot
John out in the wild and try to snuff him
out.
But as the film continues, hardly a moment
goes by where John isn't beset by highly trained
killers just, like, hanging around, waiting
for him to stroll by.
It raises a pretty big question: just how
many people in this universe earn a living
wage as an assassin?
Are all of these people just trading the same
pile of money back and forth as each one of
them kills some other assassin for one reason
or another?
Shouldn't they have run out of assassins by
now?
And do literally all of them have side jobs
as subway violinists, dog walkers, or cab
drivers?
New York is expensive — you gotta hussle
if you want to make your rent.
Chances are good most landlords won't take
fancy gold coins in lieu of a check.
In June 2017, news hit the web that the filmmakers
behind the John Wick franchise had plans to
develop a TV show set in the same universe
called The Continental.
The show will reportedly be set in the New
York-based hotel of the same name, though
it will supposedly feature a new cast of characters
that will only somewhat intersect with the
characters we've met in the movie franchise.
Knowing all this helps make sense of the turn
of events towards the end of the film, when
the Adjudicator agrees to allow Winston to
retain control of the Continental, and to
restore its status as neutral ground for the
world's assassins.
You can't have a show about the assassin hotel
if the hotel goes out of business, right?
And yet, Ian McShane, the actor who plays
Winston, has reportedly said that he has no
plans to appear in the show.
So will the show recast the part to keep the
character around?
Or will he conveniently be on vacation out
in the country somewhere throughout the show's
run?
Maybe he'll just throw out his back, and won't
ever leave the couch in the Continental's
back room, where no one can see him.
Yeah, that's probably what they'll do.
Now, here's the biggest question of all.
After agreeing to let Winston keep control
over his hotel, the Adjudicator declares that
John Wick remains a big problem: he's still
excommunicado for breaking the Continental's
rules in the previous movie, and he hasn't
fulfilled his mission to kill Winston per
his deal with the Elder.
In response, Winston grabs a gun and shoots
John repeatedly — pointedly aiming for his
bullet-proof suit, rather than his head — and
Wick falls off the roof of the hotel, bouncing
off of a couple fire escapes before he thuds
onto the ground like Wile E. Coyote.
And just like Wile E. Coyote, Wick is still
breathing after his monumental fall.
By the end of the film, he and the Bowery
King vowed to take revenge on the High Table
in the next film, John Wick Chapter 4: Who
Let the Dogs Out.
But when Winston learns that Wick is possibly
still alive, he doesn't seem all that surprised.
And yet, by any reasonable measure of logic
and physics, even in a world as cartoonishly
violent as the one John Wick inhabits, Wick
for sure should have been a smear on the pavement.
Does Winston know something we don't about
John Wick's skeleton and organs?
Is he secretly a cyborg?
Or is this really all just taking place in
the Matrix, and now Neo and Morpheus are going
to team up to take it to the machines one
last time?
Because this is for sure all happening in
the Matrix, right?
Fingers crossed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.